Speaker 1: Costco has stopped stocking excuse
me, my pillow products.
My pillow CEO Mike Lyndell is furious about
this.
Now, if you don't know who Michael Andalus,
congratulations.
You've avoided one of the most toxic elements
of the last year of the news.
Mike Lyndell is a CEO of a company called
My Pillow.
He sells pillows mostly on right wing TV and
radio.
At the beginning of the pandemic, he was front
and center because Donald Trump invited him
to the White House to announce that he would
be retooling some of his factories to produce
masks rather than pillows.
When we tried to actually figure out how many
masks did they really produce, it's unclear,
but it seems the number is extraordinarily
low.
Mike Lyndell at that point started talking
about how Trump is a gift from God to the
United States and generally went completely
off the deep end after the November election.
Mike Lyndell was one of the primary promulgates
on Newsmax and Fox News and other channels
of completely baseless conspiracy theories
about the election and with all sorts of claims,
including recently, that Donald Trump will
be resuming power, I believe he said in August
or something like that.
So this guy is completely off the rails.
And as a result, because we have, you know,
a sort of free market and businesses can decide
what to do, some retailers have decided to
stop selling my my pillow pillows.
And before Costco made the decision, Kroger
had already done the same, Lyndell now says
at least 22 retailers have stopped selling
his pillows since January.
And that includes Sam's Club and Kohl's and
Bed, Bath and Beyond.
Mike Lyndell has also announced that he will
be launching a new online store to compete
against Amazon.
In reality, it seems that he's launching an
online store to sell the pillows that lots
of retailers aren't selling.
He said this the other day because I'm
Speaker 4: looking at another thing we're
going to be launching, which is my store,
which is a rival to Amazon.
Speaker 1: Pretty a pretty explosive stuff
right now.
I have to tell you, I have never been to a
Costco in my life.
I think you need a membership to shop there.
I've never had one between Costco paying better
wages than lots of other retailers and dropping
my pillow.
This is sounding like a place I'm going to
have to investigate.
Maybe I should be shopping at Costco.
Lyndell is blaming Costco's decision on so-called
cancel culture.
This is actually called when you do things,
other things happen.
It's a free market.
Everybody gets to speak.
Speech can sometimes have consequences.
And not selling someone's pillows is protected
speech.
It's a business decision that businesses can
make.
No one's rights have been violated.
No one has had their membership in a protected
class used to discriminate against them or
to deny them something by council culture.
What it really is are the consequences of
a free enterprise where people can decide
what to say and what to do for themselves.
That's all that this is.
And this also gets back to what I said on
Monday.
I believe it was about people no longer understand
sorry, many people no longer understand or
never understood what counts as a fact and
what counts as an opinion.
Michael Lyndell isn't getting dropped by Costco
and others for opinions.
He's being dropped because he's spreading
demonstrably false statements about facts.
We call those lies, and they are particularly
corrosive lies, corrosive to democracy and
corrosive to national stability.
Now, as far as the my pillow user base, I've
never met anyone who bought my pillow pillow.
Could anyone really want a pillow so badly
that they would support this guy?
Or to put it a different way, everything I've
read is that the pillows aren't great.
But if the pillows were really, really good
with so many pillows out there and available,
why would anybody need this pillow?
Unless you're just trying to make a political
statement?
Are there any my pillow customers who are
not politically aligned with Mike Pillow,
with Mike Lendell from my pillow?
To me, it seems like it's just politics.
Like if you like Mike Lyndell and you want
to support a right wing company, you buy his
pillow.
I would never even think to go and look for
pillows from political actors like this.
He could be selling orthopedic shoes and it
would still just be about politics.
As far as I can tell.
If you are a leftist who knows Mike Pillow's,
I'm not doing that on purpose.
Mike Lynn, dels politics and still are getting
his pillow.
I want to hear from you.
I want to hear from it.
Tell me what is so great about the pillow
that you were ignoring his completely ridiculous
political views.
Let me know.